now is as good a time as ever to get
into Doctor Who but the show is long and
rich history may seem a little daunting
if you're a beginner so before you step
into the TARDIS here's a primer on some
of the small details that the show's
most dedicated fans would catch and now
you can to Doctor Who's lengthy first
run ended in 1989 and while an attempt
was made to resuscitate the series in
1996
it wasn't until 2005 that it finally
returned under the leadership of
executive producer Russell T Davies the
first season of the revival focused
mainly on introducing Christopher
Eccleston --zz ninth iteration of the
doctor and his familiar foes like the
Daleks but also added fan favorite
companion rose and a new season-long
mystery roses adventures on the TARDIS
took her to many far-flung locations but
wherever she and the doctor went the
words bad wolf always seemed to follow
it appears as graffiti across numerous
episodes the bad wolf corporation shows
up in bad wolf and bad wolf TV features
in the long game finally in the season 1
finale the parting of the ways it's
revealed that the bad wolf is rose
herself having looked into the heart of
the TARDIS she absorbs its energy
destroys the Daleks and sketches the
words bad wolf throughout the universe
as clues to help direct her to that
moment unfortunately the ninth doctor is
forced to absorb her energy into himself
to save her causing him to regenerate
into the 10th doctor other subtle bad
wolf references popped up during season
2 in episodes like tooth and claw and
love and monsters during what many fans
consider the most heartbreaking moment
in the show's history The Doctor and
Rose say a tearful goodbye in Dalek of
stranden also known as bad wolf Bay the
bad wolf reappeared includes throughout
season 4 as well hinting at Rose's
eventual reappearance finally in the
50th anniversary episode the day of the
doctor the moment takes the form of Rose
as the bad wolf it's a nice touch and
one that brings the series full circle
all the way back to season 1 of knew who
the doctor just wouldn't be the doctor
without his trusty blue police box
the TARDIS which stands for time and
relative dimension in space
it has the ability to travel anywhere in
time or space and can blend into its
surroundings using a chameleon circuit
of course the circuit broke on the
doctors TARDIS leaving it forever fixed
in the shape of a blue police box blame
the show's original budget but while the
outside of the TARDIS may appear
unassuming the inside like its owner is
always changing its appearance there is
one design feature however that has
remained the same through basically
every regeneration these roundels are
typically either circular or hexagonal
in shape and line the walls of the
console room the round things I love the
round thing while they generally
function as a decorative element
sometimes they've been used for more
functional purposes one was used as a
scanner during the season five episode
the Beast below and in the husbands of
River Song
a rounder was used without his knowledge
to store liquor inside the twelfth
doctors TARDIS would you like a drink
order brand brandy help yourself most
people tend to point out the same thing
the first time they walk through the
doors of the TARDIS they get inside the
mouth the insides bigger than the
outside it's big this is because of an
effect called dimensional
transcendentalism essentially the
interior literally exists in a different
dimension than the exterior due to some
nifty transdimensional engineering in
fact the TARDIS contains countless rooms
including a library and even a swimming
pool the main console room which
contains the control panel usually
undergoes the most physical changes
during the doctor's regeneration but
since the TARDIS is partially sentient
it can also change itself by choice the
doctor can also redesign certain
elements of the interior the eleventh
Doctor completely switched up the
console room between the sixth and
seventh season shortly after the 12th
doctor made a few slight modifications
to this new interior that's how I
convinced myself I think there should be
more growing things on the walls I just
had a lot of throwing things I want
these changes have prompted other
incarnations of the doctor to voice
their distaste in some way the line has
become a long-running joke on the show
ever since the second doctor first
uttered it to the third doctor during
the first multi doctor episode the three
doctors I can see you been doing the
TARDIS up a bit I don't like it the
doctors real name is one of the oldest
mysteries on the show and has been an
oft discussed topic among various
characters over the years much of the
revivals messy seventh season grapples
with the doctors true identity including
the aptly titled season finale the name
of the doctor River Song apparently knew
the doctors real name having whispered
it in the tenth doctors ear in the
library during the fourth season episode
forest of the Dead she also silently
transmits it to the TARDIS on trenzalore
in order to open the doors for the great
intelligence during the name of the
doctor while the doctor is an alias
itself he often uses other names during
his adventures to conceal his identity
one of his oldest and favorite aliases
is John Smith which he has used
frequently during his visits to earth
going all the way back to William
Hartnell's first doctor in 1963 John
Smith has made many appearances during
knew who the ninth doctor calls himself
dr. John Smith on a visit to London in
1941 during the empty child while the
eleventh Doctor uses the name in an
attempt to infiltrate sweetville
during the Crimson horror but no doctor
uses the John Smith alias more
frequently than David Tennant's 10th
doctor most famously he lives as a human
teacher named John Smith at ferrying him
school for boys in human nature in this
episode the doctor uses a chameleon arch
to rewrite his biology to become human
concealing his true Timelord self inside
a fob watch turns out the universe's
favorite Time Lord is pretty bananas for
bananas though his tastes usually change
depending on the regeneration it seems
like his love for the earth fruit has
remained constant throughout his very
long life the third doctor and companion
Joe grant give a banana to a captive in
the episode frontier in space
the sixth doctor finds a banana in his
pocket and gives it to Perry in the two
doctors during the doctor dances the
ninth doctor tells companion Rose how
much he loves bananas and swaps jack
harkness his gun for one to prevent him
from shooting a child the 11th doctor
plays the same trick on River Song so
she wouldn't kill him in let's kill
Hitler during season six but it was ten
who showed the most love for the yellow
fruit in one of whose creepiest episodes
season fours midnight the doctor
attempts to stop the possessed sky from
copying him by mentioning something
about bananas it's also revealed during
the girl in the fireplace that the 10th
doctor invented the banana daiquiri all
the way back in 18th century France
they've never even seen a banana before
always take a banana to a party Rose but
not as good although he has two hearts
and a special respiratory bypass system
the doctor sometimes needs to wear a
protective spacesuit on his adventures
on alien worlds thankfully he always
keeps one on hand and it's usually the
same one the doctor first acquired his
signature orange spacesuit in season
two's the impossible planet as he
traveled from the surface base of
sanctuary six down towards the core of
planet crop to safely back aboard the
TARDIS at the conclusion of the Satan
pit the suit found a permanent home and
owner the Tenth Doctor donned it again
for the waters of Mars but he damaged
the helmet while trying to escape the
planet
the suits next appearance was hide
colors boisterous I think it brings out
my eyes makes my eyes hurt
luckily Clara seemed to get over it she
wore the suit at least twice during her
travels with the 12th doctor in both
kill the moon and the girl who died the
doctor may be over two thousand years
old but it took until 2018 for the Time
Lord to take on a female form Jodie
Whittaker joined the series as the 13th
Doctor right when Chris Chibnall took
over a showrunner from long time who
Helmer Steven Moffat according to
Chibnall he never planned on casting
anyone but a woman but Moffat himself
may have been working on getting a
longtime her viewers used to the idea of
a woman in the title role the character
of Missy was introduced in 2014 as the
test incarnation of the master the
doctors closest friend and oddest enemy
the last time the master had appeared
was in a 2009-2010 arc having been
presumed killed in a fight with a Time
Lord named Russell on the character's
return was a double whammy not just
because she was revealed to have
survived but because she has switched
gender to then in the 2015 episode The
Magician's apprentice
Missy reveals that she has known the
doctor since the doctor was a little
girl the rest as they say is history
by the show's seventh season viewers
were beginning to learn more about Clara
Oswald the mysterious new companion to
the doctor in 2013's the rings of
akhaten it's revealed that her mother
died when she was a child and that
Oswald's mother died on March 5th 2005
this stage is significant to Doctor Who
fans for a couple of reasons first the
revival of the series hit the airwaves
in March 2005 second the specific date
of March 5th 2005 is the day in that
first episode Rose when Earth was
invaded by Orton's and when the doctor
met Rose that makes it a significant day
in the lives of two who companions
particularly for Clara whose mother it
suggested died during that Orten
onslaught since he can travel through
time as well as space the doctor has met
many historical figures such as Charles
Dickens Richard Nixon Vincent van Gogh
and memorably and frequently Queen
Elizabeth the first who sat on the
English throne from 1558 to 1603 Her
Majesty is something of a reoccurring
character on Doctor Who first appearing
in the 1965 episode of the chase here
companion Barbara asked to travel to the
Elizabethan era where she witnesses the
Queen chatting with Shakespeare the
monarch later makes a comeback as the
subject of a slowly unfolding time
hopping running joke in the 2007 episode
the Shakespeare Code the adventure ends
with the Queen ordering the doctor's
execution
flash-forward to tenants last original
appearance as the Time Lord in the 2009
Christmas special the end of time named
galaxy Allison got married perhaps
mistake good Queen Bess well let me tell
you her nickname is no longer notably
one of Queen Elizabeth's nicknames was
the Virgin Queen which is quite the
implication for the show to make the two
characters finally meet on-screen in
2013's
the day of the doctor hello
your generation is your business is icon
I'm not judging you a quaint little
school named coal hill figures
prominently in Clara's era of Doctor Who
the 50th anniversary special the day of
the doctor makes a brief stop at the
school while Clara and her love interest
Danny pink both work as teachers there
it's even the setting for the
short-lived 2016 spin-off series class
but this isn't any old random school
it's part of the shows extensive
continuity and goes all the way back to
an unearthly child episode number one of
the original series way back in 1963
during this era William Hartnell's
doctor travels with his quirky
granddaughter Susan Susan attends coal
Hill School and since she apparently
lives in the old blue police box
she arouses the curiosity of two
teachers there Ian Chesterton and
Barbara Wright Ian and Barbara quickly
become TARDIS companions just as Clara
would fifty years later they might even
have known each other too during the
modern era a sign at coal Hill lists I
Chesterton as its chairman of Governors
suggesting the doctor's first-ever
companion is still alive and kicking
during the time of the 12th doctor check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]